Okay, so you are…
The Commission
Right, the government
Kind of
European Commission = government
I suggest new laws and
implement their decisions
And you are…
The Parliament
Oh yeah
European Parliament…
You pass laws
Together with them, sadly
Who are you?
The Council
What do you do?
I pass EU laws as well
and do a bunch of other stuff
I'm made up of ministers
of each national government
Okay, so the European Council
also passes laws
No, I am the
Council of the European Union
I'm the European Council
Honestly, who chose these names?
I'm made up of the
heads of state or government
of each member state,
and I define the political priorities
and direction of the EU
I don't even know what that means
but I'll write it down…
So, you were the Council of Europe?
Nope, that's me
How did you get in here?
I was here before
they were all even born
I'm not part of the EU
We do have the same flag though
Well  you took it from me
I'm never gonna pass the exam…